So we know that the total money Grant will
earn from his sales is going to have to
account for both the money he thought he
was going to make from all of the wipers
and nozzles he thought he was going to
sell and also for the money that he will
no longer make from the canceled orders.
So that means that we can already rule out
two of our answers. These two right here,
the second and the forth, each of which
only takes into account one of those two
properties we need to have involved in our
equation. Now we also know that Grant is
not going to make as much money as he
originally thought that he would because
we need to remove the money that he would
have gotten from the cancelled orders. If
you want to remove a quantity you want to
subtract it, not add it. So that means
that this first answer choice, is the
correct one. If we picked the third
answer, then Grant would end up with more
money, since we said that both of these
quantities are positive after the orders
were cancelled than he would have before
any orders were cancelled. So that doesn't
make sense. I know that the wording of
things may have been a tiny bit confusing
here, but in the end this is all going to
help Grant out a ton, so it's worth our
effort.